2023 was a really hard year for people
financially and you may have felt that
whether it's like gosh interest rates
just continue to rise inflation feels
like it's never going to die down and
it's like your paycheck hit your account
it goes right back out and just for
normal everyday needs let alone trying
to save for a vacation or a car or
something it just seems impossible and
so that cycle can continue and so we
want to help you break out of that cycle
so I want you to join me for our January
11th event it's going to be day Ramsey
Jade warshaw George cell and myself and
we're going to talk through how to break
this cycle because we want your money
working for you so again January 11th
the break the cycle event you can click
the link in my bio to sign up and we
want to give you the tools to be able to
break out of the cycle and again I want
2024 to be a year for you financially
where you feel free and in control